high above a small town in France sits a  beautiful chapel it's a long way to the  top but you know what they say the  bigger the climb the closer to God  chapel's san michele dia grill otherwise  known as that michael of the needle is  located in Le Puy and voulez a town  roughly six hours away from Paris built  atop an extinct volcano plug that is  believed to have formed over two million  years ago this church rises nearly 300  feet from the ground and is dedicated to  the Archangel Michael the church was  commissioned by a bishop in the year 951  who wanted to commemorate his thousand  mile journey back from the Pyrenees  mountain range on average the site  receives just over 65 thousand visitors  each year and at 268 steps the climb to  the top is long but the view is quite a  reward with a 360 degree look at the  town including the surrounding volcanic  formations  [Music]  [Music]